let's go to our caller from the 647 area
code
caller from 647. who's this where are
you calling from what's on your mind
hi is this me yes we've got you turned
up as loud as you'll go and i can still
barely hear you so what what might we be
able to do
um is that better that that is better
yes
okay so i'm actually calling from canada
and i sort of have a bit more of like an
international
sort of story okay what i want to talk
about sure
so i read this blog post on mtl blog so
it's like a montreal-based publication
it's an english publication in montreal
and it said something
the title was justin trudeau is
unfortunately the world's last hope
which actually made me want to laugh
because well justin trudeau he's not
very
insanely popular in canada but then when
i thought about it
i you see the rise of like nationalism
around the world with
first like donald trump and then like
things like
theresa may in the uk being laughed out
of
like brexit negotiations in france you
got um
protests on the streets and for like
higher fuel prices
angela merkel in germany not running for
re-election the rise of
was it bolsonaro in brazil right and
here in canada you've literally got this
sort of consistency
in canadian politics that like
pseudo-progressive
mild-mannered like meek justin trudeau
who's like generally inoffensive
canadian politics have been insanely
predictable
relative to the rest of the world i mean
we got this um
rise of this guy named maxine bernier
who's like
honestly i'd say he's like a moderate
republican at worst
so i want to know what your opinion is
on this on what exactly
i'm like um why do you
think that i don't know um
i guess i'm trying to say is like if
justin trudeau really
is the world's last hope i'd say the
world is pretty doomed but
i guess what i'm trying to say is like
there's this general rise of nationalism
and like
people are like a lot of these like
for example like theresa sorry not
theresa may emmanuel macron and
angela merkel are generally perceived
like more
positively in like the international
community as
and while their domestic support is
falling and i think that's very
interesting because it shows something
about like donald trump as well like he
i kind of weird that his approval rating
sits at around like 38
39 i believe like that's what i saw most
recently
and like i don't know i find that very
interesting
okay did you have any questions for me
today
yeah i want to know what your opinion is
on uh
how exactly the world is going to pull
back from something like this like i
know it's a very like vague sort of
question pull back from what though
this rise of like right-wing nationalism
oh yes well that we we've been talking
about that extensively
i'm not i i didn't necessarily see
exactly how that
was the the the sort of uh question or
focus there of the lead-up but the there
needs to be a drastic change a lot of it
does have to do with the us i mean for
better
or worse the us is a taste maker
when it comes to a lot of the west and
when you've got the president of the
united states signaling white
nationalists and white supremacists and
anti-semites and
the anti-immigration crowd the
xenophobes that that he's their guy and
he's going to do what they want
that is only going to foment those
parties from gaining more power
in poland and uh hungary and and so many
other places so that that's a problem
we've got to deal with
thank you so much for the call really
appreciate it
today's program brought to you in part
by blinkist.com
pacman blinkist is a great service
that i use all the time what they do is
they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers
they condense them into 15-minute audio
books
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and i've
listened to a ton of books
on blinkist i recently checked out
soccernomics
by simon cooper we do have after all the
world cup
going on recently we also have been
talking about
bs jobs and there is a great new book bs
jobs by david graber
which i listened to on blinkist they're
constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy
and our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blinkist.com
pacman if you're watching on youtube i'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audio books for
about five bucks a month that's b
l i n k i s t dot com
forward slash p-a-k-m-a-n